users on the bitcoin network are growing
at an insane pace there was 1.2 million
users that were added in the last 30
days which does not include exchange
users or anything like that on chain
willy woo the og of on chain metrics
went and pulled this chart together and
he said users on the bitcoin network is
now growing at its fastest rate ever 1.2
million users were added in the last 30
days it does not include
off-chain users on exchanges which
typically sees up to 3x the number now
we know that coinbase's earnings that
just came out for q2 it was estimated
they were gonna have around
63 million verified users instead it
came in at 68 million verified users so
obviously there is much more growth than
people i'd expected in q2 what we are
seeing right now is that we are watching
this on-chain user growth 1.2 million
users uh it is the equivalent of
onboarding a country the size of el
salvador every two to three months
absolutely nuts when you start thinking
about the growth that we're experiencing
here if we then go and we look our best
friend will clemente the on chain if
willy's the og
will represent the new age of on-chain
metrics
76.8 percent of bitcoin's money supply
is held by strong hands we've known that
strong hands hold a majority of bitcoin
it now has topped 76
76.8 percent and so throughout the asset
speculative history a larger percentage
of supply became liquid that was until
march 2020 when the strong hand started
to get super aggressive and
a new type of market participant has
emerged so when we start looking at
these two data points basically the rate
of growth 1.2 million users coming on to
the network and then 76.8
of the money supply being held by strong
hands what that means is this is a
continuation of the supply squeeze
remember if the 18.7 million bitcoin or
so that are in circulation 76 of them
are being held by strong hands they're
not selling that that means that those
1.2 million people uh or entities that
are coming onto the bitcoin network just
on chain not including exchanges they
only have about 25 of the circulating
supply of bitcoin to actually attempt to
buy it means that there is less supply
available which means if you want to buy
bitcoin you will have to continue to
increase your bid the amount of money
you're willing to pay to buy that
bitcoin and therefore a supply squeeze
works where strong hands accumulate
bitcoin hold on tight new users come in
increase in demand lack of supply drives
price up i don't predict the future i
don't know what's going to happen today
or tomorrow what i do know though is
that over a long period of time bitcoin
in my personal opinion is likely to be
much much higher than it is today the
on-chain metrics do not lie you can
easily see how many users are coming on
chain 1.2 million in the last 30 days
you can easily see who's holding bitcoin
versus who's willing to sell and so we
are going to continue to cover this
because in my opinion this is the most
important story in all of finance
because this asset stands from a market
structure standpoint to continue to be
the best performing asset in the world
bitcoin was the best performing asset
over the last decade
it has not gotten the respect that it
deserves in the finance world
people now believe that history is not a
performance of the future of course that
is true but i still believe bitcoin will
be one of if not the best performing
assets moving forward and so we're going
to continue to cover this uh because if
that is true then that is going to be
one of the most important assets in the
world so joe john what do you guys think
about this data in terms of actually
watching user growth uh kind of
accelerate and take off in a way that
it's never done before and then also
just so many strong hands actually
holding such a high percentage of the
bitcoin supply yeah so i don't think
it's uh very surprising right like we
know all this bitcoin has a programmatic
supply it's constrained there's only
ever going to be 21 million bitcoin in
existence right and
18.75 million are already in circulation
or kind of uh in the market and 17 of
that have not been moved in seven years
right so that's the amount that they
think are either lost or or uh people
have died or whatever and will not come
back into circulation so that's 17 a
large portion of already kind of the
existing supply and you added on on
another 60 of that of people who haven't
uh moved the bitcoin in a year so strong
hands and and do not uh sell right so
when you think about it from the
increasing demand uh the the network
here from retail to institutional uh
just natural supply and demand economics
are gonna play out right it's a fixed
supply or contraind uh it's only gonna
be 21 million at the end and demand
keeps increasing when institutional
buyers keep coming into the market all
you really need is another few of these
countries to say hey we're going to make
a legal tender we're going to put it on
our balance sheet a couple companies do
the same thing right and you start to
quickly see how that fixed and
constrained supply is going to drive the
price much higher when you also look at
the strong hands they're not only buying
bitcoin and holding on to it but they're
also taking it off of exchanges as well
and so when you start to look at the
order books you can just see that
there's less and less bitcoin that's
actually available on the exchange
willie and will uh have both been all
over this for months now and so what
ultimately occurs is this market
structure leads to price appreciation uh
just like we saw back in october and
november that market structure set up
and then we saw five six hundred percent
increase in the price it is likely
setting up for something similar here
and when that happens then institutions
come in as well it's almost like the
price increase leads to people with fomo
that fomo drives more demand as more
demand comes in the market structure was
already set and it further drives the
price and so i don't know how high or
severe this kind of supply squeeze will
be but if we just repeat what happened
in october that was a 500 uh plus
percent right we went from 10 000 or so
to about 64 000
if that was to occur from here we're
talking about 200 plus thousand dollar
bitcoin price right and i'm not
necessarily predicting that's where
we're going i'm just saying that the
exact same market structure is setting
up and if we get a five to six x kind of
jump from this point that puts us at
over two hundred thousand dollar uh
price by the end of the year ooh is that
a price prediction that is not a price
but i still say a hundred thousand
dollars by the end of 2021 i said it
back from 2019 i'm not changing never
waffled i stuck with it and uh and i
still think that to be true but i do
think that when you start to look at the
market structure it is replicating a lot
of what we saw in october 2020 uh and
into kind of the the q4 area there and
what you saw was we literally went from
10 to 30 it was like that i mean we just
exploded upwards crossed over 30k right
around january 1st or kind of ended
december and then we went from 30 to 64
between january and march like this
stuff happens fast and so in a
compressed timeline of four to five
months what do we have rest you know
left the rest of this year four to five
months and so if we get that market
structure to kind of take off like that
i'm just saying that uh if it happened i
wouldn't be surprised right john with
these amount of users on it on the
network does that make
bitcoin's drawdowns less important or
less serious what do you mean so bitcoin
notoriously has seen you know 30 to 50
drawdowns um after the havings right of
the price does that make those drawdowns
less serious or i guess um
there's less of a drawdown because
there's more users so the supply and
demand economy so actually what happens
is when there's uh market illiquidity it
leads to more volatility right so there
was an example a couple of years ago and
i'm not gonna get all the details
correct but it was tilray which was uh
one of the first major cannabis stocks
to go public i think it went public in
the canadian markets and uh again for
over generalized manner uh they only
floated a certain portion of the stock
like let's say it was
all exactly one percent of the stock
right so if there's 100 shares they only
put one share in the market and by doing
that what happened was as users wanted
to come in or investors want to come in
and actually own that stock there wasn't
enough available so what'd they do they
all started bidding on that one percent
of the shares and so it led to this
massive price increase there was like
hundreds of percent of appreciation in
the stock it was nuts
and so what you do is you basically take
the share price multiplied by the number
of shares and you get a market cap and
the business was trading at some
ridiculous multiple it was because there
was a structural advantage for the
business by only floating so many of the
shares now they have the decision to do
that usually when that occurs what do
businesses do they take some of their
additional shares that aren't in the
market they sell them into the market
they raise capital and there's a whole
kind of capital market strategy what
we're watching here with bitcoin is that
there is no strategy there's no
centralized executive team there's no
ceo there's no board there's no any of
that stuff this is actually the reverse
this would be the equivalent of let's
say amazon stock the three of us got
together and we had you know trillions
of dollars and we started going and just
buying up as much of the amazon stock as
we could and we were able to get our
hands on 10 of the stock okay we put it
we said we're never moving it we buy 20
30 40 50 60 76
and we put it on the side and say we're
not gonna sell this what would the
amazon stock do everyone else wants to
own amazon it's all bidding on about 25
or so it would explode in price right so
this is not a bitcoin specific market
structure advantage this is how markets
work in general the difference here is
that we can very very clearly and easily
see who owns the bitcoin where is the
bitcoin sitting and are they
historically sellers buyers or just pure
holders of bitcoin because the on chain
metrics don't lie yeah
look i think it just goes back to the
sometimes it's easiest to simplify it
right and just go back to the supply and
demand and if you look at it from
everything that's happening right
countries are making bitcoin legal
tender uh companies like microstrategy
square uh and others have put hundreds
of thousands of bitcoins on their
balance sheet and purchased them there's
companies uh like crypto.com and ftx
that are spending hundreds of millions
of dollars on sponsorships now to
continue marketing their products and
you just look at it from the standpoint
of now professional athletes are taking
their salaries and their endorsement
money millions of dollars annually in
crypto right and bitcoin specifically
and then you just look at it from the
perspective of like okay what happens if
institutions start flowing back in what
if one more uh big company puts it on
their balance sheet what if one country
puts it on their balance sheet right and
you start to see how quickly it can
start to appreciate in price based on
just those supply and demand metrics of
how many people are holding it long term
are not selling how much bitcoin is lost
or out of circulation and how much is
actually coming into the market on a
supply basis every year
lack of liquidity
leads to volatility
volatility
works in both directions up and down and
with an asset like bitcoin where the
macro tailwind is that demand continues
to increase we literally saw willie
point out that it was the highest rate
of new users coming into the network uh
in a 30-day period 1.2 million new users
tends to lead to if there is going to be
lack of liquidity check and there's
going to be increased demand check then
the probability is that the price will
drastically increase in the future not
financial advice not predictions i just
am telling you what the on chain metrics
are saying hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it